what's up guys we're competency today
we're attempt in the world's fastest
table sensor so there's this Japanese
tables in this player called a
stochastic eye and he's claimed to have
the fastest serve in the world it looks
something like this
so browning the fastest way to do it is
with only topspin and you hit it with
the backhand side of the racket so not
forehand you go under I don't know why
but I think it's the reason that you get
more wrist with the backhand so it's a
faster wrist movement yeah and it's its
own so I kind of like these guys so if
the open and things that you're serving
with before and it suddenly comes with
the with the backhand answer kind of
surprise the opponent I think it's
actually easier to do with the backhand
side than the forehand side let's try a
few times
oh that wasn't in five this is really
difficult I feel like I'm doing
something wrong yeah I think we could
take some slow-mo footage of the server
currently and try to see analyze if
there is something that you're doing
wrong there let's see let's see what I'm
doing wrong okay here comes it has to
hit the white line to get the fastest
motion here the longest distance between
two edges here
too far our closer to the edge five
centimeters
here it comes good toss you know was a
beauty touch but it just went or what
yeah yeah high over the net I think the
record was too much like oh and it
should be like more more like close to
their rackets yeah otherwise he goes
like me exactly maybe I said it from too
high maybe yeah maybe lower
cuz now I hit it down maybe I should hit
it more forward if I'm lower okay new
try I'll try it slower first get the
technique yeah that was a bit slow yeah
that was the best one so far that was
quite fast
that's the right speed but it anywhere I
was close yeah that's the serve oh that
was close that was really fast actually
that was good I think you've got the
touch now clearly here it's all about
the topspin to get the kicker get good
topspin and right on the edge then you
get a faster sir
[Music]
well that definitely wasn't easy no it
was really difficult to be consistent
with the sir but I think even sure we
got it by well yeah well anyway remember
subscribe check out previous videos
there until next time
[Applause]